bonsoir le 7-8 l'actuel votre rendez
vous quotidien avec l'information locale
du lundi au vendredi 18 heures pour le
direct voici les titres de ce jeudi les
cabinets de groupe médicaux en danger
les médecins libéraux s'inquiètent et
demande aux pouvoirs publics
d'intervenir pourquoi est il si
difficile pour les jeunes praticiens de
s'installer
nous posons la question en docteur
lefébure élu au sein de l'union
régionale des professionnels de santé
médecins d'île de france les postiers
des yvelines était dans la rue
aujourd'hui de même que les avocats ces
derniers contestent une fois de plus la
réforme du financement de l'aide
juridictionnelle
les réactions les explications à suivre
dans une semaine va s'ouvrir l'open de
golf de saint quentin en yvelines les
plus grands champions internationaux qui
vont s'affronter et pour l'instant le
green est sous haute surveillance
la justice française a décidé de
transférer en belgique mehdi ne mouche
la cour d'appel de versailles vient de
se prononcer mais le suspect dans la
tuerie au musée juif de bruxelles
incarcéré à bois d'arcy a décidé de se
pourvoir en cassation
la haute juridiction dispose de 40 jours
pour se prononcer le transfert devrait
être ensuite s'opérer rapidement
nadine mouche encourt une peine de
prison à perpétuité et alors que la
justice étudier cette affaire aversa et
quelques mètres plus loin les avocats se
faisaient une nouvelle fois entendre
dans les rues depuis plusieurs mois et à
travers toute la france la profession
est en grève
elle s'oppose à la réforme du
financement de l'aide juridictionnelle
cette subvention versée par l'état pour
permettre aux plus démunis d'avoir accès
à la justice près de 9 millions de
personnes en bénéficieraient une des
pistes évoquées par l'état consisterait
à appliquer une taxe sur le chiffre
d'affaires des cabinets d'avocats ce que
ces derniers refusent ils souhaiteraient
une taxe sur les axes juridique jusqu'à
présent l'aide juridictionnelle et est
financé par un droit de timbre de 35
euros pour engager une procédure
aujourd'hui les avocats ont clairement
mis en garde le gouvernement il ya eu un
premier avertissement le 5 juin on n'a
pas été entendu puisque la seule réponse
est une forme de mépris à l'égard des
avocats de justiciables c'est serait ce
serait pardon
sur le chiffre d'affaires des avocats ce
qui est invraisemblable on ne demande
pas aux médecins de verser une taxe sur
leur chiffre d'affaires pour phil
combler ou financer le budget de la
sécurité sociale
et si nous n'avons pas à très bref délai
c'est à dire dès demain des réponses
claires sur le budget complémentaire
nécessaire pour que le jury qu elle
fonctionne et bien d'autres mouvements
auront lieu dès la semaine prochaine est
très certainement un rassemblement en
grand nombre des avocats français
nous sommes des gens très calmes et
raisonnable par nature mais il faut
quand même pas trop de marcher sur les
pieds et ça fait quelques années qu'on
nous marchent sur les pieds je crois
qu'on a pu l'accepter
dès la semaine prochaine de façon très
claire et dès demain rassemblement à
paris est annoncée les facteurs cgt de
montigny le bretonneux se sont
rassemblés ce matin devant la direction
du courrier des yvelines un mouvement de
grève a été entamée dans certaines
villes de france mais dans le
département à la mobilisation reste
faible et il se bat notamment contre les
réorganisations prévues fin octobre à
cause de la baisse du trafic de courrier
une baisse de trafic qui selon eux ne
signifie pas mois de travail et coûté ce
témoignage
il rentre dans un bâtiment pour
distribuer hier huit lettres aujourd'hui
l'enac a tu peux toujours qu'ils fassent
le même trajet qu'il aille au même
endroit et le boulot il est quasiment le
même c'est pas forcément moins de
lettres c'est pas forcément moins de
temps de travail déjà qu'aujourd'hui les
facteurs il y en a beaucoup qui termine
après l'heure sans être payés qui font
tous les jours gratuitement une demi
heure trois quart d'heure donc c'est le
ras-le-bol
c'est ça peut plus durer comme son coup
c'était au micro de yolaine thorez et
juliette
où sont la cgt qui affirme que ces
suppressions de postes vont également
avoir lieu quoi qu'il arrive une
information non confirmée cependant par
la direction du courrier jointe par
téléphone cette dernière assure
cependant qu'une réorganisation est bel
et bien prévu afin de mieux répartir les
charges de travail entre les bureaux à
déclarer un accident causé par un tiers
un acte citoyen qui pourrait faire
économiser des millions d'euros dans le
département à la sécurité sociale et
donc on contribuables c'est le message
que souhaite faire passer la caisse
d'assurance maladie
vous avez d'ailleurs peut-être aperçu
les affiches de campagne chez votre
médecin
par exemple plus d'explications avec ce
sujet réalisé par claire cambier pascal
patrick jacq ne dit il pas un animal
trop affectueux un coup reçu une
baignoire qui vous tombe sur la tête
avec ces affiches humoristiques la
caisse d'assurance maladie des yvelines
lance une vaste campagne de
communication sur le recours contre
tiers
derrière cette formulation complexe un
constat simple bon nombre d'accidents
sont causées par une tierce personne
un accident de la route une bousculade à
l'école une morsures d'animaux
même si l'accident n'est pas volontaire
les soins devraient être prises en
charge par l'assurance du responsable
finalement la sur elle pour elle dérange
pas grand chose pour moi moi jour pour
moi
dans les deux cas me faire rembourser
seule chose c'est que c'est de l'argent
public
il n'y a pas de raison que ce soit sur
l'argent public que on paye ses choix
alors que normalement ça serait une
compagnie d'assurance ou un tiers qui
devrait le payer l'enjeu est de taille
en 2013 l'assurance maladie des yvelines
a pu récupérer 18 millions d'euros au
niveau national le montant s'élève à 1
milliard et l'on estime que seul un
tiers des cas sont déclarés en 2013 près
de cinq mille accidents ont été
officiellement causé par un tiers
responsable à 60% des cas d accidents de
la route
car un protocole facilite les échanges
avec les assurances pour déclarer un cas
trois options sont possibles par mail
sur le site ameli.fr par courrier ou par
téléphone au 36 46 des partenariats sont
également mises en place avec les
instances médicales et les forces de
l'ordre
donc là nous venons de ce travail et
beaucoup d'établissements du département
parce que les acteurs ont changé il faut
re mobiliser à chaque fois pour qu'ils
soient bien conscients de l'importance
et qui nous avertissent le plus
rapidement possible des affiches
devraient être distribués en septembre
dans les établissements scolaires pour
rappeler qu'être responsable ne signifie
pas être coupable
la cellule emploi de la mairie
d'elancourt proposait ce jeudi un forum
emploi sur le thème vente directe à
domicile prêt-à-porter maquillage
ustensiles de
le forum permettait de présenter au
public et des professionnels du secteur
un public qui comprend aussi des
demandeurs d'emploi ou encore des
retraités voir des personnes cherchant
un complément alors revenu à l'occasion
idéale de rencontrer de séduire un
potentiel employeur
comment se passent les changes on
commence d'abord par découvrir la
personne qu'on a en face de soi et voir
quelles sont ses aspirations
on n'est qu'au début du salon mais j'ai
déjà rencontré trois personnes dont tu
ne me paraît très intéressés par notre
secteur d'activité je voulais en fait
savoir je suis satisfait pour le moment
au pôle emploi
je me suis déplacé tout simplement pour
ça et je trouve que c'est une excellente
idée
donc voila et je découvre par exemple
histoire d'astellia
c'est excellent de quoi repartir
heureuse oui ils te gagner sa vie
j'espère et plein d'espoir car sur place
olivier maniscalco et patrick jacques de
dixmude politique le responsable de
l'opposition à la verrière interpelle le
meilleur dans un courrier nicolas
dainville divers droite demandent aux
communistes à l'arrachage de réagir
après plusieurs incidents incendies de
voitures de matériel de chantier il
souhaite une mise en place rapide de
vidéoprotection et d'une police
municipale 24 heures sur 24
dans le même temps la ville de la
verrière vient de voir 60% de ces
logements sortir de la zone prioritaire
en matière de politique de la ville ce
qui signifie une diminution des aides de
l'état au chesnay à présent le cinéma du
centre commercial parly ii a
définitivement fermé ses portes
l'exploitant qui gère ce complexe est
également les salles du cirano et du
roxana versailles a expliqué que sa
décision a été prise par un manque de
rentabilité ils déplorent un manque de
soutien pour relancer ce complexe datant
des années 70 qui n'a jamais réellement
connu de rénovation
seuls 270 milles cinéphiles se déplaçait
encore ici sur un bassin potentiel de
700 mille entrées l exploitant assure en
revanche que ces salles de versailles ne
sont pas menacées aujourd'hui
l'entreprise adoma qui propose des
logements sociaux à celles et ceux qui
rencontrent des difficultés économiques
ou à d'insertion a fait travailler ses
résidents d'elancourt sur une peinture
murale et une tenture monumentale à
l'association
l'occasion d'associer d'associer les
résidents à ce travail le reportage de
mathilde eu qu'à berne et patrick
jacques de dixmude pour ses résidents
d'adoma à elancourt cette journée la
concrétisation de ces années de travail
l'association ad ca dh intervient
gratuitement dans ces centres
leur but apporter un bien-être aux
personnes défavorisées discriminés ou
isolées grâce à la peinture abstraite
c'est un travail qui demande beaucoup de
rigueur est ce que je voudrais souligner
dans ce travail
encore une fois que c'est un travail
collectif donc qui incite les stagiaires
au respect les uns des autres
parce que chacun écoute l'avis de l'un
ou de l'autre par rapport à la
construction
donc ça c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
très très importants et un respect de
l'autre et il ya cet esprit de ceux de
convivialité patrick a participé au
projet dès son origine
youssef lui suit activement l'atelier
depuis devant j'étais là comme pour
fermer des hommes mais là on prend les
gens que des décennies un petit peu sur
les schémas mais je restais place
spécialement pour voir les défauts ni
quand je voyais des géniales bas j'ai
fait quand même mais bon j'ai tracé à
passer le temps quelle télé ferme mais
j'espère que ça sera développé à travers
certaines sa vision de la france
ça donne un peu la con viabilité en
faire les gens et puis je pensais ça
vient partie
ap le loisir le projet fini
l'association a défait à dh devrait par
ailleurs se rendre dans d'autres centres
d'adoma en france quant aux résidents
artistes d'elancourt il pourrait trouver
une place dans un atelier d'arts
plastiques de la ville
si on peut éventuellement aider ou
effectivement à des inscriptions sur les
cours d'arts plastiques de la commune et
leur faire découvrir aussi autre chose
pour les professeurs là aussi si le ccs
peut intervenir le ferai avec grand
plaisir
une harmonie de formes et de couleurs
règne dans la salle polyvalente de la
résidence un travail d'équipé
plus de 100 résidents ont permis la
création de la tenture et de la peinture
murale l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé médecins
s'inquiètent de l'avenir des cabinets de
groupe il en existe 1080 en ile de
france 80 % se déclarent fragilisé
pourquoi ces inquiétudes et surtout
quelles conséquences bonsoir docteur
patricia lefébure merci d'être venus en
plateau médecin généraliste à vélizy et
lui a lu rps est ce que vous faites
partie des 80 % professionnels exerçant
en cabinet de groupe à être inquiet je
suis kamikaze parce que j'exerçais de
façon seul dans mon cabinet et je vais
intégrer un cabinet de groupe puisque la
ville de vélizy nous montrent une maison
médicale et
et voilà donc c'est attractif donc
c'était apporter des professionnels
inquiets inquiète mois voilà mais en
tout cas pourquoi c'est un cas pourquoi
il existe aujourd'hui ses inquiétudes
pour les cabinets de groupe donc on
retrouve plusieurs plusieurs professions
plus spécialité de bain c'est c'est
l'inquiétude elle est justifiée parce
que on a en a de nombreux exemples de
cabinets de groupe qui ferment entre le
début on a fait une enquête entre le
début et la fin de l'enquêté avait déjà
sur moins de six mois il y avait déjà 3
3 cabinets qui avait fermé parce que
financièrement ce n'est pas viable c'est
ce qu'on appelle le syndrome du cabinet
vide
c'est à dire que les cabinets ont été
les cabinets groupe ont été construits
dans les années 70 80 et à l'époque où
il n'y avait pas de problème de botro et
des médecins et les conditions de vie
étaient bons convenable et aujourd'hui à
chaque fois qu'un médecin par la
retraite un médecin libéral par la
retraite il n'est pas remplacé donc les
ceux qui restent doivent payer des
loyers de tout le monde quoi c'est comme
si vous étiez célibataire avec un seul
revenu et qu'on vous oblige à louer un
cinq-pièces donc c'est assez difficile
il suffisamment pour payer les loyers de
ces cabines danser dans la région
parisienne évidemment le prix du loyer
est un gros problème voilà et donc ça
fait boule de neige parce qu'il y en a
un qui peut plus payer il s'en va les
suivants bas ils ont encore plus de
freins ils peuvent plus payer puis au
bout d'un moment ça ferme quoi tout ça
parce que le départ d'un d'un seul
médecin n'y a pas assez de marge de
manoeuvre et le départ d'un seul médecin
peut fragiliser l'ensemble du cabinet
les cabinets de groupe donc ce sont ces
lieux je vous le disais on trouve ces
différents praticiens de différentes
spécialités différents médecins on va
écouter à un témoignage à présent d'un
de vos collègues voisins le bretonneux
le reportage de yolaine torres aucune
secrétaire à l'accueil juste une chaise
vide
c'est l'une des conséquences des
difficultés rencontrées par ce cabinet
de groupe médical à voisins le
bretonneux
alors qu'elle était quatre auparavant la
dernière secrétaire sera licencié au 1er
juillet en cause des charges financières
trop lourdes dans le cabinet certains
médecins vont partir en retraite et un
seul départ suffit à fragiliser le
groupe parce que les autres médecins qui
ont déjà du mal à assurer les charges
n'arrive plus à
ainsi pouvoir assumer les charges
financières qui deviennent trop
longtemps d'après une étude de l'ue rps
ile-de-france -près de 30% des médecins
exerçant en groupe ont plus de 60 ans
d'après ce généraliste l'exercice
libéral n'attire plus du tout les jeunes
médecins pour une simple raison
l'évolution des mentalités je crois que
les mentalités ont changé à partir du
moment où s'est installée une politique
des 35 heures en france
alors bien sûr les médecins ne sont pas
à 35 heures mais les jeunes médecins
actuelle refuse totalement de consacrer
70 heures par semaine à leur travail ils
souhaitent améliorer leur qualité de vie
pouvoir avoir une vie de famille ce qui
n'était pas toujours le cas de nos
générations à venir c'est l'une des
raisons essentielles
ce cabinet a voisins le bretonneux n'est
pas un cas isolé
toujours d'après une étude de l'ue rps
80% des cabinets de groupe médicaux
d'ile-de-france sont fragilisées et à
terme dans les trois ans quarante pour
cent de ces cabinets serait menacé de
fermeture selon le médecin les
difficultés serait aussi lié aux
contraintes administratives qui pèsent
sur la profession et les conséquences
pourraient être très importantes
il ya un risque réel de voir disparaître
une offre de soins dans des régions
aussi proches que celles de versailles
rambouillet où la moyenne d'âge des
médecins est très très élevé et où le
remplacement ne se fait pas sur waza
même
j'ai appris
le départ très proche
d'un des médecins qui ne part pas en
retraite mais qui fuit l'exercice
libéral pour se réfugier dans un
exercice salariés beaucoup plus
confortable sans apporter de blâme ce
confrère
et si les cabinets sont moins nombreux
d'après lui les patients se dirigerait
plus dans les hôpitaux au risque de les
encombrer encore davantage une des
solutions qu'il évoque la mise en place
des contrats aidés pour les cabinets
médicaux
bien qu'il soit passionné par son métier
ce médecin à 68 ans et quarante années
d'exercice aimerait bien trouver un jour
un successeur et nous continuons donc à
parler de ce sujet avec le docteur
patricia lefébure peut-être votre
réaction sur la situation de votre
confrère et sur une des choses qui était
dit ce sont aussi que la réalité c'est
que les jeunes maintenant veulent moins
s'engager que les médecins par le passé
il donne un confort de vie aussi je
dirais qu'ils sont réalistes
oui oui non bon déjà donc tant le
principe je me bats contre ont dit les
jeunes les vieux voilà il ya des vieux
médecin qui travaille pas beaucoup et
des jeunes médecins qui travaillent
énormément ça c'est pas le problème ne
s'est pas la charge de travail qui leur
fait peur c'est les conditions les
conditions de vie que nous avons
effectivement je dirais que là on peut
les comprendre un autre à salaire et il
fait un revenu on va dire est revenu ce
nom n'est pas salarié évidemment à
revenu égal on vous dit est ce que
voulait travailler 40 heures ou 72
heures bal effectivement bon mais
beaucoup de deux médecins m nos
condisciples aime le travail que nous
faisons voilà n aime pas les conditions
dans lesquelles nous exerçons et il l'a
très bien très bien dit ce qui tout
nouveau depuis cinq six ans maintenant
il ya à peu près un médecin en france
par jour qui qui qui dévisse sa place
bien avant l'âge de la retraite et ça ça
ne s'était jamais vu autre fois et à
chaque fois c'est des gens qui partent
vos dires des médecins qui porte la mort
dans l'âme quoi qu'ils adorent ce métier
de médecin généraliste
parce que la plupart du temps ce sont
des généralistes et mais simplement les
conditions de vie sont difficiles et
donc les jeunes regardent ça et puis
étudie la situation tout à fait de façon
claire quelles seraient les solutions
pour redynamiser un petit peu la
profession et faire venir ces jeunes
médecins à les faire intégrer les
beatles a fait tout à fait alors là je
parle évidemment au niveau local enfin
en région parisienne et partiront dans
la banlieue ouest de paris
il y aurait à faire de sueur de deux
manières quoi au niveau des
collectivités effectivement aider ce qui
est quand même dommage pour une
profession libérale mais enfin parce que
normalement on se débrouille tout seul
mais bon dd par des loyers attractifs 1
c'est simplement ça donc de faire des de
nous faire des conditions de loyers très
plus facile que que loyer habituel
essentiellement aussi consolider
l'existant
donc il parle du médecin qui appartient
pas la retraite mais qui a des visées sa
plaque comme on dit parce que beaucoup
de j'ai rencontré beaucoup de mères qui
construisent une belle maison médicale
effectivement la limite qu'ils sont
prêts à faire un geste pour pour les
loyers et ensuite lui met une petite
annonce en disant vous emmener les
remplir non le il faut d'abord aller
voir les médecins les crises sur cela
voilà il faut les associer leur proposer
des choses intéressantes
les médecins sont très ouverts sont tout
à fait sont pas du tout en piste et dans
leur mode d'exercice et est donc faire
des projets avec les professionnels
actuels et ensuite de ce qui sépare ya
en plus un cabinet où il y aurait que
des jeunes qui arriverait d'abord celui
topic
et puis en plus c'est pas assez pas
souhaitable les jeunes aussi qui veulent
venir ils veulent être accompagnés par
les anciens donc voilà faire un cabinet
mixte où il ya des anciens et qui attire
les jeunes au niveau collectivités les
maires de bonne foi n'ont pas forcément
toujours bien compris ça et puis je
dirai au niveau de vous
les auditeurs qui est aussi en général
des patients de l'auditeur qui ne
consultent jamais intervenir auprès de
vos élus auprès de l'asepam est
essentiellement près de vos élus parce
que pour dire simplement il faut
augmenter quand même un peu le prix de
la consultation qui est à 23 euros pour
un généraliste 27 euros c'est là que les
patients met la main à la poche pour
continuer je n'en sais rien ça s'est
passé ces décisions politiques que je
n'ai pas à auquel je n'ai pas de
revanche mais en ce cas vous faire
pression auprès des élus parce que alors
qu'angers les élus c'est essentiellement
pour revenir sur sur les lacs aide les
caisses de sécurité sociale mais ils
n'ont pas eu de pression directement
dessus mais auprès des élus parce que
une étude avait bien montré qu'ils
montraient dans des cabinets de groupe
pour avoir le comment dire le service
minimal un jeu perdu je parle pas du
grand luxe un lueur ps avait donc fait
une étude de médico économique qui
disait que pour vous donc auditeurs
patients si vous voulez ce qu'on appelle
le service minimal c'est simplement un
cabinet aux normes d'hygiène quoi avec
un ménage correctement fait avec du
matériel pour vous soigner aux normes
récent pas non plus le truc up to date
mais correct quoi voilà un accueil au
secrétariat c'est ce qui c'est qui le
montrait tout à l'heure il ya plus de il
ya plus de secrétaire qui soit ouvert de
8h à 20h quoi ça me paraît logique
et bien pour ça il manque 10 mille euros
par mois et par professionnels de santé
par an et dont un par mois excusez-moi
par an donc c'est à peu près 1000 euros
par mois et donc je calculais que simple
augmentation de 2 ou 3 euros sur la
consultation sap rsa simplement par le
sénat permettrait d'absorber ce coup en
plus ce qui évidemment aiderait à ceux
qui sont là déjà resté et puis espérons
les jeunes à venir également le risque
aujourd'hui c'est de voir disparaître
clairement ces cabinets de notre
relation mais deux groupes mais il est
seul aux 6 1 voilà exactement 1 c'est à
dire que on a vite eu sur les cabinets
groupe parce que on présente ça
aujourd'hui comme justement la panacée
il ya un problème de médecin il suffit
de cabine secret des cabinets groupés et
tout ira bien
non parce qu'elle cabinet groupe qui
existent déjà ils n'arrivent pas
survivre et donc les cabinets de groupe
qui se crée si c'est dans les mêmes
conditions que nous avons aujourd'hui
non on pourra pas plus vivre les centres
de santé ferme aussi alors qu'ils sont
très aidés qui a pas ils ont pas le
problème des prix du loyer
les centres de santé aussi ferme donc
effectivement il faut réviser le système
de financement et chacun peut agir à son
niveau
le risque c'est de voir donc fermé c'est
différent un cabinet de médecin est
notre question du jour aujourd'hui le
micro-trottoir le tourner autour de
cette difficulté à prendre rendez-vous
ou non chez le médecin vos témoignages
avec ce micro trottoir de jonathan
wilmet médecin traitant c'est sans
rendez vous donc j'y vais comme je veux
et les autres entre trois semaines
un mois et demi mais enfin ça le vin je
le sais donc il n'ya pas de problème
particulier pour moi c'est assez
difficile car c'est maintenant il faut
prévoir en soi une malade trois mois
rose donc ça va qu'une mission dans les
15 jours maximum chez jenny rendez vous
je n'ai jamais des problèmes que je
perds la démo m'a été donné en peinture
pas toujours quand je me mets quand même
assez rapidement voilà vous savez pas
lequel mais celle ci s'est notamment par
l'ensemble des titres quand même à temps
de quelques mois mais ça comme normal ou
presque dans l'urgence qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'un médecin en jarle on est
obligé de partir en urgence datant de
trois heures et s'est pas laissée pas
vraiment pratique
c'est vraiment difficile
les difficultés qui sont rencontrés dès
à présent on entendu par les patients
qui ont du mal à prendre rendez vous
avec les médecins qui du coup sont de
moins en moins nombreux juste pour
conclure cet entretien une pétition et
est en place vous avez décidé d'alerter
encore plus les pouvoirs publics
notamment
tout est fait au niveau du rps
exactement à signer une pétition pour
l'instant pas signé par les médecins
mais pourquoi pas une cité une pétition
signée la passion peuvent toujours
passer leur message
merci d'être venu nous parler de ses
difficultés rencontrées par les médecins
en plateau vous l'avez compris les
difficultés qui vont s'aggraver ainsi on
vous écoute si dans les prochaines
années si l'on n'y fait rien oui merci à
vous on termine par du sport dans une
semaine sera donné le coup d'envoi de
l'alstom open de france au golf national
l'heure est aux derniers réglages sur un
parcours qui sera de plus en plus
spectaculaire chaque année d'ici à la
ryder cup en 2018 anthony rech les
tentes du village sont en place
l'arrosage automatique fonctionne à
plein régime
à une semaine du coup d'envoi de
l'alstom open de france les effectifs
ont été multipliés par 2 pour tailler
les derniers centimètres de gazon non
l'équipe des terrains on travaille à 12
cents personnes parce qu'on n'a pas les
yeux et donc pour faire du bruit avec
notre machine traversions fairway il
faut pas regarder les deux côtés on sait
qu'il n'ya pas aucune du r&b travail
depuis cinq jours le parcours est fermée
au public
l'objectif le laisser respirer revêtir
sa robe finale pour le d
la compétition en vue de la ryder cup
2018 quelques évolutions ont été
apportées à l'albatros en 2014
les green seront plus denses et les
zones de ruck mieux taillé en interne au
fn on mélangeait and rave pleuvait faire
arrêter là avec plus de 50000
spectateurs l'an passé l'alstom open de
france reste aussi la fête du golfe pour
les visiteurs des concours de sortie de
bunker seront notamment organisés en
parallèle de la compétition et pour les
professionnels premiers swings prévue le
3 juillet prochain
merci de nous avoir suivi sur tv fil 78
prochaine édition du 7 8 l'aktu demain
vendredi 26 juin excellente soirée les
programmes se poursuivre sur notre
antenne